ce bâtiment résidentiel vient d'être
touché par un missile
sa façade éventrée
réussi à s'échapper on a eu de la chance
parce qu'on était dans la cuisine quand
le premier bombardement a touché
l'entrée ma femme et mon fils aîné ont
des jambes cassées mon cadet a été
ramené quelque part par les secours je
suis en train de chercher des tirs de
missiles et des combats ont lieu à
plusieurs endroits de la capitale
faisant corps de troupes régulières
russe mais l'armée ukrainienne dit avoir
repoussé une attaque sur l'une des
artères principales
le président ukrainien lance un nouvel
appel à la mobilisation
nous résistons avec succès mais les
affrontements continuent un peu partout
dans le pays nous nous battons pour
protéger nos terres et l'avenir de nos
enfants nous gardons le contrôle de kiev
et de points stratégiques autour de la
ville alors que les assaillants tentent
de prendre le contrôle de tout notre
pays les russes concentrent leurs
attaques sur kiev au nord du pays et
kharkiv un peu plus au sud mais ils ont
également frappé d'autres villes à kiev
après l'assaut nocturne des forces
russes les habitants se préparent au
pire ce matin sept hommes creusent une
tranchée en plein milieu d'une route de
la capitale les rues sont désertes des
familles entières se terrent dans les
sous sols de bâtiments résidentiels
pour ceux qui ont choisi de partir
l'exode continue cent mille personnes
ont déjà été déplacées selon l'onu